alright so today we're going to talk
about Big Data international trade and
how panjiva is creating transparency
through information I'm Peter this Keith
so yeah so today we're going to talk
about the importance of global trade why
this is something you should care about
the promise of trade data what we can do
with it if we can extract valuable
information from trade data the
technical challenges that we face and
doing this and the solutions we've put
into place the business applications how
it's useful to our clients and parties
involved international trade around the
world and two takeaways that we've got
both from the technical side and the
business side lessons we've learned so
the concept of panjiva is very broadly
that global trade is very important
field and if we can understand it better
there's lots of value to be gained
global trade touches all current all
countries so what we see in this figure
is we can see country the relative size
of exporters from different countries as
exporters from 2005 to 2013 the you'll
see that the usual suspects are quite
large China is very large the u.s. is
large Germany's large but the more
general point is that pretty much every
country in the world is exporting pretty
much every country in the world is
involved with international trade
moreover global trades just very very
big in 2013 it was valued at 18 trillion
dollars and it's growing nine times
since 1981 is valued at about 2 trillion
so a map of this network would be
extremely useful so if we could
understand this network as a series of
companies connected by the links between
them or more generally entities
connected by the business they do
together we would have something very
very valuable for manufacturers and
retailers will be able to tell you
basically who makes a given good you
could find different trading partners
you could see what your competitors are
doing for logistics companies you're
able to see what's going in and out of
different ports the individual items
going who is involved in those
transactions who you can call up to get
new new business for whatever type of
vessel you have you can also just
optimize your investment across ports
for governments you can manage trade you
can encourage trade that you desire
you can discourage trade that you don't
desire such as illegal or illicit trade
smuggling in finance it's obviously very
helpful to have a sense of the overall
health of economies with as little lag
as possible additionally you can look at
individual companies there's commodity
trading there's all sorts of things you
can do with this data so what's the
opportunity the opportunity is that
there's very valuable information being
generated there's just tons of it the
according the WTO the average stack of
export documents is 1.5 centimeters
thick so there's just governments are
just very very interested in
understanding what's going across their
borders there's generating tons and tons
and tons of paperwork but the flip side
of that is that there's tons and tons of
paperwork being generated in these very
sort of arcane formats and all sorts of
forms with all sorts of free text it's
this very similar question to which many
of you are dealing with but it's just
data that's not structured very well but
has very very valuable information
therein moreover there's a complex set
of privacy laws that can impede
acquisition or dissemination of this
data it very much varies by government
what you're going to have access to some
governments are gonna be very open some
ribbons are going to give you basically
nothing so the challenge is to do this
in a way that respects the laws of the
government's you're working with but
some things the extracts as much value
as possible so at P&G what we're doing
is we're mapping this network of trade
we're basically making this network and
we have data from eight governments this
is customs level usually transaction
level data so we see the individual
transaction going across a border and we
have this data from the US China Mexico
Chile Colombia Panama Peru and airway
overall we actually get visibility in
290 countries because some of these
governments that we just listed actually
provide also the data on the foreign
party involved in a transaction so even
if data was not to be available for
example from France we can nevertheless
see many French companies this applies
around the world we have about 450
million shipping records and we have
structured five million distinct
companies based on this data that are
involved international trade we actually
have many more based upon our pulling in
data from other sources such as in a
marketplace websites things like that
but i think the real meat of the product
and what makes this valuable is those
those profiles of companies that are
enriched with trade data and you can see
their position in this network it's it's
useful to take a look at what the data
usually looks like so here we have an
example of us import data we can see
that this is shipments going across the
u.s. border the arrival date is very
recently we can see that there's a
shipper field here listed as Ross
shipper this is what was listed in the
form as it went across the border you
can see it's Samsung in Korea is
shipping to Samsung in the u.s. there's
we have the port that it came in at Long
Beach we have the item refrigerator
presumably plural familiar or lots of
refrigerators in that shipment probably
and yeah and so and you can see also
that there's just we're just showing 6
of 35 columns in this case we actually
have 35 fields per shipment from the US
government and then for other data sets
such as some of the Latin American data
sets we can actually have hundreds of
fields so there's just tons of valuable
information so what's the technical
challenge the technical challenge is
that the raw data is pretty raw we've
got a range of data partners there's a
wide variety of data formats that we're
getting the data in there's a wide
variety of regulations and rules about
how we can use this data and it's pretty
messy data there's really like if we're
lucky you'll get a tax ID but usually
you won't like in the US data there's no
unique identifiers for these companies
there's just these unstructured there's
just these text fields where you have a
company name and an address and you want
to make something valuable out of that
but you have like 450 million records
there's a pathological aversion to
spellcheck I mean this stuff is being
filled out by people who are at the
ports or they're just they may or may
not be native English speakers they they
just rushed I mean this is not a
priority necessarily to fill this out in
a clear manner it's pretty pretty bottom
of the barrel you've got records in
multiple languages if we buy get records
from a Latin American country from for
government for example then we expect
them to be in Spanish the Chinese
records the company names if we're lucky
we'll get an English name but otherwise
you'll just have the Chinese name and
just have the Chinese address in Chinese
so what's the steps so what we do is in
very broad terms that it's a two-stage
process we get the raw data
from the government whichever government
we're dealing with we receive the data
in whatever formats available in CSV
sometimes PDF unfortunately more arcane
formats that are just there we upload
the raw data to our database and we try
and preserve its structure as much as
possible the information there and
before processing it so that if we ever
have to go back to the ground truth we
can then redo everything very easily we
solve the data available this is subject
to storing it efficiently of course some
sort of normalization procedure we also
structure the road text so there's sort
of an intermediate cleaning step where
we want to extract we want to parse that
raw text and pull out information that's
easily extractable such as the
geographic location of parties we'd like
to structure that information and
understand what cities being referenced
what state is being referenced what
region what country what's the street
address etc this this understanding of
the address will allow us to build many
things on top of it and also just allow
refinement so you can see where all the
companies are geo-located ports we
simply pull up port information units of
measure if that's not pulled out in a
separate field from a given government
would like to pull that out it's very
interesting to know exactly how much of
a given item is being shipped then we
engage in a more advanced processing and
what we want to do is we want to take
this raw data as transaction-level day
and we want to cluster it into profiles
of companies and then we want to
understand the links between those
profiles so here's an example of one
shipment of petroleum related goods I
believe its petroleum related equipment
that went across the border fairly
recently and we can see that the shipper
is coming from Mexico its PMI commercio
international the consignee who's sort
of the direct more or less the primary
recipient is Atlantic trading and
marketing in Houston Texas but we also
have them listed also in the notify
parties notify parties can be people who
are also related to the shipment for
whatever reason finance logistics etc
and we also have total petrochemicals
and refining involved with this shipment
it's what we want to do is we want to
tag this we're going to take this record
to actually our semantic understanding
of these three companies that are here
note that one of them is repeated and we
do that through a machine layering based
comparison of sort of the features the
measures of symbol of the of these
records of the addresses and names
contained therein and they
from that we can sort of get we can tag
this to the right company we do this
through intelligent feature extraction
we thought deeply about similarity of
addresses similarity of names how to
understand where the information is
contained in company names across
different countries and then we want to
both do this within a given data set
robust to different languages and
different ways of writing things and
then we want to match this to other data
sets so for example you make clusters of
companies based upon the US data you'd
also like to match that to the China
data s then you can see this company
from multiple perspectives because you
have the foreign party so what's the
technical take away the technical take
away from me and what I've one of the
important things I've learned from this
work is that you really want to
generalize from domain expertise data
science is great machine learning is
great but you really really want to
understand your data wire fields blank
what does it mean why our wire address
is being written this way what is this
field labeled as one thing but sometimes
it contains other things you want to
look at the data and you want to
understand it it's really important the
reason for this is that then you can
understand like why you're getting
things wrong but more generally you want
to take that you want to then push
yourself one step further and you want
to research general ways of
understanding the domain what I mean by
this is when I look let's say that I'm
trying to understand just matching
addresses together so I've already
thought about I've already thought about
sort of general pathologies in there and
I could make a great rule based system
maybe about matching together address
let me see like I'd say if it has this
number of shared words then I above five
which I've just like I bald that's great
then that's going to work and were going
to match them together that's probably
not the way to do it you probably want
to have a more advanced technique that's
letting a machine learner set the set
thresholds set the function that gives
you a measure of classifies it into a
match or not a match but more generally
let's say that I'm like a real expert so
we've agreed that we're not going to use
rule 'both rule based methods but then
we want to think intelligently about
constructing features really use your
domain expertise but don't just let
yourself stop and say okay I'm a man I'm
a native mandarin speaker and so I right
addresses from the most general
administrative region to the smallest i
started country and i go to street and
then i've noticed that
in a lot of the other records it starts
at the most specific and goes the most
general i started street and I go to
country that's the Nets the normal way
for native English speakers right in a
dress so what you want to think about is
okay so I just flip them and compare
them that could be okay now now we've
got sort of the addresses by naeve
measure of string similarity look pretty
similar when they are pretty similar but
what if we end up with a third country
that writes the city then the street
then the country or just maybe people
just like to write things in just
arbitrary orders because they're in a
hurry so what I'd really encourage you
to do is think more generally really
push yourself about why you can
understand an address is similar to
another address and why the machine can
understand the domain understand your
heirs and then generalize it don't stop
halfway I'm now going to hand over to
Keith and he's going to talk about the
business so I'm going to talk a little
bit about the platform and what we do
with all of this data that Peter spends
every day behind monitors perfecting for
us basically one of the things that has
been I think a common theme in the
conference here that I've seen is that
people are very interested in the
results from big data they're not
necessarily always interested in the raw
data and we've realized that in our
customer base as well so one of our
goals at pangea is to create actionable
data and kind of going back to what
Peter discussed about thinking about the
data and what it means very deeply we
know that of all of the use cases of all
the interesting use cases there are a
couple superclasses of use cases that we
see most commonly to extract contact
information to find corporate data
whether that's SEC filings financial
reports product information trade
partners and what we do is we package
all of these kind of super classes of
actions into different delivery methods
we have a subscription website we also
have a free website for basic research
we have a CRM tool that we are deploying
in the East right now that allows
factories to work with buyers in the
West without having to hire intermediary
parties and track those relationships
we've also developed an API that allows
companies that might have sensitive data
proprietary data to pull the information
in to their systems and run analysis in
conjunction with their own and form a
without having to divulge it to us and
finally we do provide custom solutions
to people who want us to run their
entire analysis what this looks like at
a really broad level is we have a data
source that's acquired by our business
team it goes through our pipeline and
lands in the databases as Peter just
discussed and then we create kind of an
ecosystem of applications that sit on
top of that database and this allows us
to do a few things one to constantly
improve the data on the back end and add
more information restructure it will
without interfering with our clients
workload in two it allows us to deliver
very client specific applications that
are extremely simple and streamlined
since the data itself is so complicated
and messy especially when you start
adding information from other countries
it's a big help to be able to pick the
individual action that you want to do
and work only on that at one time so
there a couple of simple business cases
here that we see these super classes
that we roll up to the simplest case is
the supply chain case where we have some
intermediary party or a factory or a
buyer who wants to find or vet a trading
partner and this is pretty apparent from
from what peter was talking about
basically you can go on to the system
you can look at this data and rather
than having to pore through what used to
be hundreds or thousands or in some
cases hundreds of thousands of documents
that are one and a half centimeters
thick each you simply type in the name
of the company you're interested in or
some product that they produce and find
the location that interests you and
you're presented with what is
effectively a graphical overview of all
of the information you could want to
begin to vet them and these are what the
profiles that Peter mentioned earlier
look like we basically have summary data
that allows you to see product images of
past production see all of the shipments
from any data source or any government
from which we collect the information we
have a separate break out for Chinese
data because it's such high value
there's a lot of overview statistics
there we extract customer data and
supply network data and actually graph
it for you in real time and allow you to
move through a trade network click by
click we put all of the corporate
information into tabs and contact data
as well as allowing you to get directly
in contact with people through the
platform whether through VoIP click to
dial messaging
anything of that nature and that's a
very basic case the intermediary case
that's a little more interesting adding
some abstraction on that is for
logistics and the shipping industry so
the common problem there is that these
companies need to figure out how to
optimize their shipment flows between
ports and trade lanes and while they
have their own information and can
clearly see what works for them in the
the viewpoint of their company what
they're missing what they've been
missing previously was the ability to
look at data from other shipping lines
other nvocc s other freight forwarders
and then make value add propositions to
customers based on their ability to peel
the customers off other people's
business and add them to their own trade
lanes for less money so what people will
do is they will maybe analyze a port
let's say I'm interested in the port of
LA which is what I've pulled up in this
particular instance and we can quickly
get a sense of where trade is coming
from clicking into each one of these
will actually expand more specific
statistics related to it but this is a
great overview now if I decide hey I
want to do business in the port of LA
but I only have maybe ten million
dollars to spend on I'm contracting on
port space on whatever provisions I need
to get to that port I can actually very
quickly in two steps go through all all
60 million 66 million u.s. import
records that we have on the system by
clicking two buttons see the top players
by tu by matching shipments by weight in
some cases by value in some cases by
taxation my certifications I can select
the individual things that I would need
to have like hazmat permits and things
of that nature and it will automatically
Korra just collate that data for you and
beneath this is more information about
each individual company so it's a really
interesting case that takes away from
having to kind of guess about your
competitors activities to actually
knowing what they're doing in your port
I think the most advanced case goes back
to the the third and the fourth delivery
methods that we briefly talked about
which our API and custom solutions and
that's in this particular instance
governments general Amos governments as
Peter said are very interested in
promoting positive trade and making sure
that bad things don't come across their
borders which can be very difficult and
one of the difficulties with the data
that Peter didn't touch on is that not
only do people have a pathological
aversion to spell
correctly or spell checking but people
actually specifically game the system
they will actually work in one country
to obfuscate what they're shipping to
prevent paying tariffs or to prevent
being inspected or to prevent having bad
food stopped at a port and they will do
that the entire time that the ship is in
transit to their benefit and it's a very
common occurrence so governments of
course are interested in understanding
how are we going to stop these shipments
we can't have a bunch of people at every
port looking at every container but what
we can do is compare container
descriptions across country borders and
understand what one government is
inspecting it might not care about and
what we do care about or vice versa so
in this case we're looking for these
anomalies at a very large scale and
there's no really beautiful slide for me
to show you about that because it's a
lot of just data work but that's kind of
our most advanced case so what's the
business take away that the fact is it's
actually the same as the technical take
away which is we need domain expertise
it's really interesting to just pull
stats from the data to run basic
analyses on the information to find kind
of anomalous readings using just math
which I like to do on my own but the the
problem is that each individual company
has a specific need and while we know we
can't answer each specific need we know
we can't answer the kind of super class
of question and that means we work very
very closely with our customers with the
government's we work with with our data
partners and then we connect them
directly to our engineering departments
so there's a lot of customer and
government to engineer relation that you
don't see a lot of other places and then
we construct these front-end and
back-end systems to handle those cases
the future for panjiva currently what we
see what's next we're always trying to
acquire more data obviously the more
governments that report the more
visibility that we have into fraud
transactions or value transactions
things of that nature we're also looking
for higher quality data and going back
to what the gentleman from dun &
bradstreet mentioned yesterday in his
presentation was not just gathering
higher quality data but understanding
fundamentally what quality means and the
sense of trade data is it more fields is
it more information is it better
spelling all of that's under
investigation for creating more tools
for a wider range of clients but still
keeping the platform really
CTU's and making it as open as possible
for transparency sake and then finally
for custom services both creating
applications to help large businesses
gain value or in the sense of customs
services helping countries manage their
ports more effectively and in a more
automated fashion so with that I will
open it up for questions and if you guys
don't have any questions now you can
feel free to contact us our information
is up on the screen